Let's talk now about the Rand Paul story I
mentioned earlier.
Kentucky Republican Senator Rand Paul yesterday
went on Fox News and he chose feelings over
facts.
I thought they were the facts over feelings,
people.
Rand Paul had a very embarrassing day in total
yesterday.
There had they had a Senate hearing where
Dr. Foushee, Dr. Redfield and others testified.
And Rand Paul sort of scolded Anthony Foushee,
telling him, you know, you're not the end-all.
You just want opinion.
And we got to look at what other countries
are doing as well, including Sweden, which
we'll talk about.
But then Rand Paul went on Fox News in the
evening to talk about the new so-called obamma
Gate scandal.
This is a totally fake trumped up scandal
to distract from Donald Trump's incredible
failure on Corona virus.
And Rand Paul asserts to Martha MacCallum
that Barack Obama gave direct oversight and
guidance on unmasking Donald Trump's former
national security adviser, Michael Flynn.
The Fox News host, Martha MacCallum, asks
the right question, which is, do you have
evidence of that?
And Rand Paul says, I'm not I'm not kidding.
You're going to see here I have a strong feeling.
He has a feeling, but no facts.
Take a look at it.
Trump campaign.
I really strongly believe that President Obama
gave specific and direct oversight and direct
permission for this.
Think about it.
We have never allowed a secret court to be
used against a presidential campaign.
Don't you think that was sensitive enough
that it went all the way to the very top?
So, yeah, the media have treated President
Obama with kid gloves.
One needs to ask him directly, did you approve
a process of operation CROSSFIRE, hurricane
and other cancers?
Yes.
So, you know, I mean, to put the shoe on the
other foot, a lot of it is, do you have evidence
of that?
You say you're sure that the president, the
former president was involved in this.
Why are you so sure?
Well, we'll find out.
I'm hoping that a lot of this will be declassified,
but I have a strong feeling that this was
such a sensitive subject.
He's already admitted or admitted through
people that worked for him that the Flynn
investigation he knew a lot about.
And I strongly believe I think the answer
is yes.
But do you have evidence?
Well, no, but I have a feeling this is downright
irresponsible for a sitting U.S. senator to
be saying if Rand Paul had a shred of evidence
for his claims, he would have provided it
by now.
But he doesn't have any evidence.
So instead he has his feelings.
Since when do sitting senators go on television
and accuse former presidents of wrongdoing,
allegedly criminal wrongdoing on the basis
of feelings?
I guess now is the answer to that.
So that was Rand Paul choosing feelings over
facts on Fox News earlier in the day.
Here is Rand Paul going after Dr. Foushee.
Remember that Rand Paul got Corona virus while
he was waiting for his test results.
He went to the Senate gym and worked out.
Turns out he was positive during that workout.
Now he's refusing to wear a mask.
And here he is scolding Dr. Foushee during
yesterday's Senate hearing, which is I respect
you, Dr. Foushee.
I don't think you're the end at all.
I don't think you're the one person that gets
to make a decision.
We can listen to your advice.
But there are people on the other side saying
there's not going to be a surge and then we
can safely open the economy and the factual
to bear this out.
But if we keep kids out of school for another
year, what's going to happen is that the poor
and underprivileged kids who don't have a
parent that's able to teach them at home are
not going to learn for a full year.
And I think we ought to look at the Swedish
model and we ought to look at letting our
kids get back to school.
Is a huge mistake if we don't open the schools
in the fall.
Thank you.
Now, Rand Paul mentioned Sweden.
Let's talk about Sweden a little bit.
Sweden, much like chloroquine, has become
a political football.
And for me, just like with chloroquine, I
have no emotional attachment to Sweden did
the right thing or Sweden didn't do the right
thing.
What happened in Sweden is that older and
vulnerable folks isolated and stayed at home.
But young people mostly haven't.
There's been mild social distancing in bars
and restaurants.
Schools stayed open.
Young people, for the most part, lived close
to their normal lives.
What do we know so far?
Well, so far, Sweden's death rate is the ninth
highest in the world.
If you eliminate tiny countries like San Marino
and Andorra, Sweden's death rate right now
is the sixth highest in the world out of more
than 180 countries.
So what we can say is that so far at this
point in the pandemic, Sweden's plan has led
to a really high death rate.
Now, let's be fair.
Does that mean Sweden's plan failed?
Not necessarily, because it's possible.
It's possible that because Sweden is doing
this and having more a higher death rate now,
it could get them more immunity and potentially,
potentially Sweden could end up with lower
deaths during wave two and wave three if.
There is one, so I again, I just want the
truth.
If Sweden's plan worked, then great.
We should all know it.
If it didn't work, then we should all know
it.
So far, Sweden's death rate is very high.
But if they end up with more immunity by the
time wave to hits, which could wave to could
be worse than wave one, we don't know yet.
Sweden may end up in the long term for the
total pandemic.
They could end up with a lower death rate.
We just don't know yet.
Now, Dr. Foushee responded, I.
He also doesn't think he's the be all end
all.
He's just a public health professional.
Here's how he handled it.
First of all, Senator Paul, thank you for
your comments.
I have never made myself out to be the end
all and only voice in this.
I'm a scientist, a physician and a public
health official.
I give advice according to the best scientific
evidence.
There are a number of other people come into
that and give advice that are more related
to the things that you spoke about, the need
to get the country back open again and economically.
I don't give advice about economic things.
I don't get advice about anything other than
public health.
So I wanted to respond to that.
The second thing is that you use the word
we should be humble about what we don't know.
And I think that falls under the fact that
we don't know everything about this virus
and we really better be very careful, particularly
when it comes to children.
So I think you get the idea.
Anthony Foushee not getting rattled by Rand
Paul, making him the enemy.
I know we talked about this, but what kind
of a sick country are we that a doctor who's
been doing this for decades and has worked
for I think it's six presidents is now the
enemy.
Bogus documentaries are being made where Dr.
Foushee is the villain.
People are attempting to concoct false sexual
assault allegations against Dr. Foushee.
As I told you about earlier, crowds at protests
are screaming Fire Foushee.
Yesterday I did a story about the world is
laughing at us.
The treatment of health experts by the Trump
crowd during this pandemic is a big part of
why the world is laughing at us.
Absolutely sick.
And notice, of course, that Dr Foushee has
now been gone for weeks.
From any Trump administration press briefing,
Corona Virus Task Force event, he's still
doing interviews.
He testified before the Senate, but he has
been disappeared, as we talk to you about
a couple of weeks ago